it's a good part of town my ass that's a
good party to hell we go walk around
with open containers are you [ __ ]
kidding me
he's lot of people [ __ ]
walk around and open [ __ ] container
what's wrong with people these are the
same people involved the trouble just
sitting there wondering who's wrong for
Trump the same people tell you listen
you gotta come visit me there's a great
little party town cussing and then you
walk around with an open container
now that's what you're looking for on a
[ __ ] Wednesday morning W K&Z the
Dutch station what's happening you bad
[ __ ] uncle Joey it's cloudy
ain't no bird sang it the [ __ ]
squirrels ain't even chirping but you
know what it's still a beautiful
[ __ ] day to be alive believing
that you bad [ __ ] uncle Joey
don't make it a little better at least
set your compass and the right
[ __ ] direction you understand
me
I'm Sydney a slump into a tremendous
reef is this morning in this room and
also and then we got some of this
[ __ ] that Larry ogi respectful
[ __ ] talking Larry get him thinking
but enough with the talking let's get to
talking you follow me cuz that's all
that [ __ ] matters in my world I got a
big date today bats he's [ __ ] me
pants I leave them outside to say snow
like ten dead [ __ ] Iranians but what
are you gonna do young Sam I got a new
bleep ass they're on the way I have two
different ones and they come out more
sweaty and [ __ ] you think I sucked a
thousand pigs but I just got beat up the
family but it's Wednesday what is it
June 15 that got less than 30 days from
the [ __ ] view we'll get surgeries i
bombed at the store last night
and get ready issue the special man so I
got a start for [ __ ] zero here you
follow me I got some material clamped up
for you but you know it's an hour long
[ __ ] I gotta sit up there so I love you
too out there and [ __ ] Beantown and
I'm saying I'm a [ __ ] Aerosmith I
think you guys have already stolen three
girls it's 10:00 tonight who the [ __ ] do
you think you're dealing with I already
wrote down my goals I took [ __ ] number
one it's not gonna take [ __ ] in the
middle that's coming after this [ __ ]
look at that that'll get your [ __ ]
morning cookie with [ __ ] gas
[ __ ] if you ain't puffing clouds
a jar like that if we can slip and [ __ ]
you and your little filter and your joy
your little [ __ ] crook it add that's
not what the [ __ ] leaf is about it's
about you get the full book page that's
in fact the police comes in gonna get
that [ __ ] smoke that luteum [ __ ]
stomach and then like this
we kept saying there's no [ __ ] filter
these little half of fact gentle houses
vapor pass I do this on a natch
which means you got to get your [ __ ]
together you got to go back into
training see when I was a young [ __ ]
man 1819 I lived in [ __ ] Aspen
Colorado and the [ __ ] hair is light
up there you gotta get acclimated
brackla minute myself i doing bong his
vaccinations you understand me within
six weeks I'm [ __ ] gorilla lungs thank
you really I got shot Chicago either
suck my dick I would've ran and still be
[ __ ] running but nobody is the
cigarette the blow [ __ ] diaphragm the
fatness you know what I'm gonna do at
least I'm honest with myself I might
just Sydney is saying you know what
happened hey you know what happened
[ __ ] you turn to [ __ ] egg creams
and your [ __ ] lights fell down
that's what happens when you become a
fat [ __ ] I'm saying but anyway that's a
different [ __ ] story we don't have to
get to that waistline
why start the day off on a negative
[ __ ] Bank you follow me anyway I'm
happy you're happy
we got a podcast we're eight o'clock to
plan and drill class today I'm going
deep that I have two meetings today I
[ __ ] need some dude to write it you
know it never ends but this is it as I'm
53 years old get them you gotta keep
[ __ ] work and even if I had 22
[ __ ] million buried on Bharati you've
got a bang around because if you stop
using it you're [ __ ] Lutz
and you gotta keep you know I tell
[ __ ] all the time
you gotta sign your [ __ ] couch and
that happens I gotta [ __ ] get up
snack playing your little [ __ ] games
and you wonder what where's my legs
you know I beat my friend last night I
call it dude whatever the [ __ ] it is you
know get your might be playing games I'm
playing games as I was [ __ ] - oh let
me get my place [ __ ] keeps and I
advise for you to [ __ ] do the same to
you follow me you got a great little
party to have it people walk around
openly Tanner's the [ __ ] is wrong with
people these are the same people and
we'll see sons of Lennox get it and
[ __ ] you know get excited
um
anyway uncle Joey here coming the right
day it's a beautiful day you gotta get
out there you gotta [ __ ] it you know I
don't even know what the town my heart
still goes out to the [ __ ] Orlando
victims my man angel how long did a
tremendous interview yesterday none of
us could have [ __ ] made it to that
none of us people get those poor [ __ ]
people
I might even talk about gayness I'm
talking about [ __ ] the human beings
brother what they those people I'd
survive that
it's not [ __ ] good but my heart goes
out to them and you should set your mind
to [ __ ] that you will never want
to go they gonna do that for us have you
thought about that they're going through
that far so give them the [ __ ]
respect they deserve mother [ __ ] okay
beside that you can almost suck my dick
it Wednesday I'm going for broke to the
LZ as usual
what if you get I caught them go for
broke today [ __ ] these [ __ ]
young Sam keep crawling seven put it on
the arm I don't give a [ __ ] at the end
I'm gonna [ __ ] beat you even if you
give up even if I give up I still won't
let you [ __ ] win [ __ ] how's
that boy that's it from stone to the
gills I'm tuned up I got my [ __ ] arm
smoothly
I wrote my goal for that
I wrote my plans and now I gotta [ __ ]
back makes the day a lot easier
I got no comment I just I podcast
tonight 8:00 p.m. be there or be [ __ ]
square Philadelphia you know what said
Friday and Saturday already [ __ ] sold
out so I don't know what to tell you you
got Thursday language to me it's gonna
be [ __ ] crazy
you what listen any jerk-off who brought
in the Friday and Saturday night it's
the [ __ ] the one on Thursday
those ones you gotta worry but I don't
give a [ __ ] about a call here but I'm
drop the sleeping pills cough medicine
bad sorts Gorilla Biscuits a little
reefer to balance everything out you
know Sammy's the reefer keeps our
altogether playmon you [ __ ] knew that
uncle Joey here I hope you have a
[ __ ] great day you know keep your
eyes open you don't want to repeat this
I've always keep guys well we don't need
to look at the phone in the daytime you
don't need to look at the phone that's a
funny maymay next thing you know you get
shot the [ __ ] ahead maybe don't even
look I don't even look at memnos oh I
don't give a [ __ ] about Malaysian the
entertainments in my head I'm at the
pain of myself while I'm [ __ ]
watching these creepy [ __ ]
cuz you always gotta watch just like
Donny you don't want to be in a casket
little [ __ ] Joe is your listen no I
don't need to put you know forget about
that you know if people tell you stories
and they look at their don't even look
they just keep walking [ __ ] straight
they keep you look that way I'll look
this way okay
that's the man that'll keep you guys up
my love you [ __ ] boss to the
Iroquois yeah I thought I'm weighted I
think I'm imagine to wire go grab me a
claw me see I am a delicate metal
allowing would have brought the cool
wire yosaku a Nietzsche oh no doubt the
others never forget that don't know if
it will [ __ ] y'all but what if you came
that's what keeps you going everyday
[ __ ] these [ __ ] trying to be
fake and trying to be something they're
not
they came from me some shitty neighbor
better hang that will wake it you know
we got our tarts get the [ __ ] out of my
face you grew up on [ __ ] an egg
between 90s anyway why you get me all
fired up I love you have a good day see
you tonight 8:00 p.m.